did you tidy up at all before you got on
national television with me beth
look at you did you do any did you think
at all like i should probably
maybe try to straighten it up a little
bit
did you give it any thought
i got some what do i got there's a shirt
on a chair
i have some laundry over in that corner
uh-huh it's just to prove it
it does say
is that a heart or a butt it's a butt
it looked like a butt to me that's
actually a perfect rendering of your
butt
i memorized it that is what my yeah
sadly
my wife will attest drawn to scale he
has seen my butt
and uh that's that's about it it's
actual size
um i saw you have a cello is that a
cello you have in the background
yeah you want me to that's what i that's
what i could have put between you and
taps
a little a little ode to joy from me on
there
yeah well it's funny because you have
you're actually in a much nicer room
than i thought you were you just
chose you look fantastic don't get me
wrong
you look lovely but the r the room is so
much nicer
you chose this this terrible angle
because you
know what you're doing you were in the
most depressing corner of your house
you know i usually have a here's a
beautiful thing i usually have beanbag
chairs but they're too hot
they're too hot yeah it's too hot for a
beanbag chair right now
oh i thought you meant like too sexy
no i like beanbag chairs but they're
just too sexy
yeah no one can handle it look you have
a lovely place
this is a fan oh that's your yeah that's
great oh look at you
go you go
[Applause]
this has turned into a tour yeah i
should have done this
this is fantastic i should have been
right here that's fair
see every everything we've seen is much
nicer than what you do
so i'm sorry i'm just telling you
okay well we learned a lesson i think we
did
i'm going to change who i am yeah no
no just the room i'm in the fan the fan
is great by the way
that fan is just killer that's that's
the new look for you
thank you flowing always wind blown
flowing you have that going for you too
without even the fan
i'm just going for this now i'm going to
it's pretty soon
it's going to come straight down here
and i'm going to have to cut out a
little window right here
that's what i'm going to do um listen
i want to congratulate you again on your
hilarious special
thank you really funny and uh there's
also thank you for making it
well you know i appreciate you i
i appreciate you being so funny and and
being so talented
and girl daddy look at that even the hat
hbo max watch it please
we'd love it if you watched it yeah
critics love it it's great yeah twins
all right i'll put mine on too and we
called your mom podcast is available
wherever
you get your podcasts let's go
keep on keeping busy i will all right
thank you beth
thank you appreciate you